thank you everyone for being here
tonight instagram live uh
youtube and here on the zoom we're so
happy to have you here if you're new to
dr wallach
this man is a living legend a
veterinarian a pathologist
with over 20 000 autopsies under his
belt and a naturopathic physician who
has done wonders for the health and
longevity across the world
thank you so much for being here tonight
dr wallock we always love having you
here
and we can't wait to hear what you have
to talk about tonight
[Music]
thank you travis thank your team i
always appreciate being with you
uh getting the message out there and um
of course i don't know if you remember
a year and a half ago when all this
started
dr anthony fauci came out and said we
actually have film of him being
interviewed on tv and news
things and he said that this covet thing
is
is nothing it'll be gone in a couple of
weeks just
wash your hands wear a mask and distance
yourself and be over within a couple of
weeks
what did we get for listening to him for
almost a year and a half
as of this morning we have 32 million
61 286 infections
577 109 dead
that doesn't sound like a nothing to me
okay that's in less than a year and a
half
and an arlington cemetery where we have
our military dead from the civil war
up until now okay a hundred years of
wars
uh uh uh we only have four hundred
thousand graves
uh fauci beat that in a year okay and he
still has a job i'm just amazed
well it turns out that uh everybody's
waiting for the vaccinations that's the
medical
view of things so you get a vaccination
and it'll take care of everything
well there's three pieces to a
vaccination they never talk to you about
the other two they always talk about the
vaccination
and as a result people think that
vaccinations kill viruses bacteria
fungus and yeast back
vaccines don't kill bugs vaccines alert
your body
and your immune system to the bad dna
and rna in the bugs
so when the bug shows up they say ah
there it is there's a bad guy
and they send out the white blood cells
and the t lymphocytes and the
um antibodies and red blood cells the
platelets go kill and eat the viruses or
the bacteria the fungus or the easter
whatever's attacking you well um this is
problematic
because the other two pieces have to be
dealt with to be able to respond to the
vaccination
and they never talk about they never
ever talk about the other two pieces
number one
you have to be able to absorb nutrition
the villi in your intestines make you
know your intestines when you open up a
intestine during surgery
or an autopsy the intestines look like a
shag rug
all these villi's sticking up like 90
percent of the surface area the
intestine are these villi
okay well when you eat gluten
wheat broth around oats or drink it beer
scotch bourbon rye whiskey
that kind of stuff the gluten produces a
substance called pro-inflammatory
cytokines which kill the villi so
from the moment you start eating gluten
when you're a baby and and
it gets worse every year you're slowly
losing those villi
and depending on how much gluten you eat
and whether eating one meal a week or
three meals a day
uh it depends on the speed at which your
villi totally disappear now you only
have two percent
of your intestinal surface and your
intestines instead of looking like a
shag rug they look like oh
a plastic tube you don't have any the
surface that's why
a three to five year old baby when they
get the coronavirus infection
okay the cover 19 they will have
common cold like symptoms for two or
three days a little fever maybe a cough
and then after that's over with they got
antibodies against it they're safe for
life
now when a 12 year old 20 year old 30
year old 40 year old 50 year old
six-year-old seven-year-old
has been eating gluten all their life
those villi are gone you've got this
plastic tube
two percent absorbent surface if you're
not supplementing
you're doomed okay because you you can't
get everything you need from your food
you must
supplement and when a doctor tells you
when you ask them shouldn't i be
supplementing take some vitamin
d like yours you need that doctor should
be put in jail as a serial killer
mass murderer because you cannot get
everything you need from your food
plants only need three
minerals give the farmer the maximum
meals and farmers get paid by tons and
bushels for acres they don't get paid by
the nutritional value of the food
okay so you can call any fertilizer
company on the phone and say you know
i'm planning on
i'm planting some corn here in some
sizable um
tracks of land i'm going to plant some
wheat what's your best fertilizer how
many minerals do you have
in your best fertilizer for corn and
wheat and they'll say three
because that will give you the maximum
tonnage and bushel what are you where
are you going to get the other 57
minerals you need 60 okay well we know
that in the agricultural industry that's
why we don't need health insurance for
animals
because we give them all the vitamins
and minerals otherwise the veterinarian
be living out there
and you have to pay you'd lose your farm
to the veterinarian okay
so we learned if we just give vitamins
minerals to the animals they don't get
sick
she said simple well um
let's just look at our status of this
new bug
um first of all i have to say that this
pandemic is nothing new if you're
a student of the bible or you've heard
the bible stories once or so
you understand that there's plagues to
go back that's how the good lord
got the pharaoh to release um the
hebrews had been a slave for
400 years in in egypt he sent eight
plagues upon them you know one plague
every year for eight years
okay and when thousands died then the
pharaoh said uh i better get rid of
these hebrews
as moses said let his people go kind of
stuff right
well um when you look at it
this particular brand of plague we have
now this pandemic which is
just a new modern word for plague
it started at three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 on
pearl street
in new york city and the bluff
overlooking the construction of the
brooklyn bridge when thomas edison and
jonathan liebs
pulled the switch in the first
commercial electric generating plant
and within 10 years we had all these new
diseases nobody ever seen before but it
happened to be the darling moment
for genetics and so doctors are saying
well these are genetic diseases
they've never seen them before they're
all just nutritional deficiencies
because all the minerals that used to be
in the wood ashes
in the wood stove and the fireplace in
the fire pit we used to put in the
garden
and grandma would put in her oatmeal and
she'd put them in her
soup and that's sort of her goulash and
whatever
her all kinds of soups
it was gone and so people began to get
these diseases which were all mineral
deficiency diseases
now doctors haven't changed and they
said people began to gain weight
right around 1900 and they're 25
50 pounds overweight which is due to a
nutritional deficiency because people
get a behavior called pica p-i-c-a
pica and they begin to want to eat
everything
frank you just had a 5 000 calorie
breakfast what are you doing you're
eating another breakfast i don't know
i'm still hungry
that's because they're deficient that
mineral well about 1900
we began to have obese people there was
never obese people in america before
1900.
if you wanted to see a fat lady you had
to go to a carnival and see the fat lady
and you paid two bucks to see if that
lady weighed 200 pounds
okay now i treat them they weigh 300 400
500 pounds
okay because they don't supplement they
eat gluten so they can't get whatever
nutrition might be in the food
and they're just hungry all the time and
kids
during the second world war when mama
had to give up breastfeeding go to the
factory make bullets and guns and tanks
and things for the second war
um they came up with baby foods like
infamil and similac
for the babies but they only put three
minerals in there now for 25 years i've
tried to get
the medical profession to put more
minerals in the baby farmers and they
say no no
well like they're they're they're
poisonous you can't put those minerals
in there
so dr milan and i went to
china we did one thousand seven hundred
autopsies on kids under the age of ten
that died what was called keyshawn
disease in heilum zhong province
keyshawn university published in three
languages the english one
is the biology of trace element research
okay it was published in 1990.
we did we did the study in 1988. okay
and um of those 1 700 autopsies 35
percent have cystic fibrosis supposed to
be the classic
genetic disease transmitted to kids 100
had muscular dystrophy
and 200 of them under the age of one
year
would have been diagnosed with sediment
syndrome here in the united states
but they're all deficient in one
nutrient
so we got to publish we took it and we
gave jerry lewis a marvin romp a great
navy seal i've been working with in the
amish uh countries
uh and because they have a high rate of
mustard history
and we were curing them right left and
center so we gave 12
charts to um jerry lewis okay i don't
know if you're old enough to remember
the telethon for
25 30 years where it was he ran the
telethon he wrote he raised billions of
dollars to find the cause
and cure for most history so make a long
story short in 2011 we gave him about a
dozen
of these charts of kids that marvin
robin i had worked on and the doctors
had signed off that
yeah they were born with muscles we
don't have any more the oldest one we
treated and reversed was a 31 year old
guy
we gave those charts to jerry lewis he
was so excited he took him
after he confirmed with the doctors he
could he took him to
the most christian association and they
fired him before he turned around walked
out the door
that's whatever happened to jerry lewis
in the telethon it all ended in 2011
because he brought them the cure and
they didn't want to find the cure
and so they tried the telethon and they
couldn't run it without jerry lewis and
that was the end of
the um mischievous association
well it turns out that there are no
genetically transmitted diseases there
are no objectively transmitted birth
defects now so my thesis on twenty
thousand autopsies is in the smithsonian
institute's national treasure i'm very
proud of that
and um people can go to siri and say hey
siri
and they put a hard cover on it made it
a textbook okay
it's called the diseases of exotic
animals because i was doing autopsies in
zoos and people who live near the zoos
were looking for a canary in the mine
you know the canaries coal miners would
take them down the mine
and the gases would come to mind the
canaries were more sensitive they drop
off the perch and die the coal miners
would get out
well the whole purpose was to find a
species of animals in the big zoos the
big cities
were sensitive the same pollutants that
humans were because pollution was a big
deal back then
and um we would find one that died of
the same pollution the people died from
and when they started dying in zoos we
could evacuate the cities that was the
whole
reason of the project that's why we got
25 million bucks
well to make a long story short um
during that
10-year period 1967 1977
not one animal in the zoo died of
pollution not one person living around
the zoo died of pollution
we found that none of the birth defects
are genetic and they're all just simple
nutritional deficiencies and all of them
can be prevented many of them can be
reversed after the baby's born
you know like cleft pellet is
preventable but when they're born
there's a surgery case you can't give
them the vitamin
and the mineral and they make it go away
it's a surgical case
um stuff like cystic fibrosis must feed
we can reverse those okay even when
they're born with them
uh sentiment death syndrome um and of
course
i'll interrupt there um in 19
let's see here in 2013
april 16 2013 uh we brought all that
data including those 1
700 autopsies to a federal court and
demanded that they put these nutrition
things in the baby farmers
well they couldn't argue with 1 700
autopsies
so they moved and they decreed that they
had to put
these minerals into the baby farmers now
you see about 17 18 minerals in there
instead of three
make a long story short a year and a
half later september 13
2014 big headlines in the charlotte
observer big newspaper for charlotte
north carolina kind of like
new york times for new york he said we
don't know why but cinnamon
syndrome has vanished in the state of
north carolina
and three months later i called him and
left him a message they never contacted
me
three months later saint louis post
dispatch and all the newspapers in
missouri came out and said
we don't know why but senator ness
syndrome has vanished in the state of
missouri
and three months later all the
newspapers the world came out and said
we don't know why but the diagnosis of
sediment death syndrome
has dropped dramatically by 85 to 95
percent
and then about um
a month ago the cdc center disease
control came out and said
uh uh um 15 years ago
one kid for 300 normal births would die
of sediment death syndrome
it was 15 years ago today is one in
three thousand
now it's a huge improvement between one
and three hundred and three thousand
well that's because mothers are still
giving them goats milk and stuff like
that
or they're breastfeeding the baby and
they're not supplementing and so
those babies is one out of three
thousand they're still dying of that
nutritional deficiency
it's the same nutritional deficiency
that causes sudden heart death in young
athletes about 500
000 a year in america alone okay
now i want to say
we didn't get a complete picture yet we
don't get a complete picture till the
end of the day
but things are spiking like crazy
okay and you have to appreciate
that um the top one two three four
out of the top eight um states in which
the states all have more than two
million
or assuming they have more than a
million cases
okay there's one two three four have
two million plus california is almost at
4 million
just short of 4 million and um texas
is 2.8 million florida is 2.1 million
and new york just just got over 2
million okay
they've been 1 million 900 000 forever
now
today the number of cases new cases
is sixty nine thousand four hundred
forty four as of two o'clock
now they're not going to shut that off
until midnight tonight and so this could
be eighty thousand a hundred thousand
new
infections today okay this is also from
the cdc
right now it says 69 445
new cases just today and again i'm going
to go to
florida has 96
new cases today reported pennsylvania
has 6
120. new york has 4 348.
michigan has 10 277
and new jersey has eight hundred forty
eight now
there's dozens of states that have more
than one thousand to three thousand
new cases today it'll be added to their
totals
okay and so this is an ongoing thing
because they haven't dealt with the
problem
now how we're going to deal with the
problem again vaccinations
don't kill the bugs they just alert your
body to the bad dna and rna
so i started making comparisons on earth
what what places had the most
infections and deaths from the
coronavirus which places had very few or
none
well it turns out i got 50 different
comparisons
between states between states and
countries that had
and countries and countries that had
wide
variations in the number of cases and
deaths but they had the same population
number
let me give you a couple of times excuse
me
if i may uh let's start out
with um florida and taiwan
both of them have 22 million people
and florida has um 34 000
dead taiwan has tended not 10 000 just
ten
florida has three million one hundred
eighteen thousand seven hundred and
thirteen
infections taiwan has a thousand
infections yet they have the same
population
what's the difference florida when you
look at them by county
they have so many counties that have 40
50 60 latinos
blacks indigenous peoples native
americans
all of whom eat nothing but wheat
brought around oats okay
whereas taiwan is a classic asian
country
and they live on maize corn rice sweet
potatoes bean squash and seaweed
which has all these trace minerals in it
which the bone marrow likes to be able
to make antibodies and wipe those cells
let's look at a couple more let's look
at texas
and let's compare texas with
vietnam vietnam has 97 million people
texas has 29 million people about a
third of the population they have a
third of the population of vietnam
vietnam has 35 dead from the covid
texas has 50 000 dead vietnam
again with 97 million people have 2 600
infections and texas has just short
of three million infections what's the
difference well again texas like florida
40 50 60 percent of the people who live
in certain
counties are latinos blacks and
indigenous peoples
and they their villa are dead because
they're eating gluten
they don't supplement whereas the
vietnamese like the
taiwanese they're classic asians they
just live on
maize corn rice sweet potatoes bean
squash
and algae which is minerals from the
ocean
one of my favorites is nigeria and
brazil this tells a big story
both nigeria and brazil have about 208
million people
nigeria is 98 black
tribal people 90
brazil same population 208 million
okay um they are 47
white europeans that immigrated there a
couple hundred years ago
there are 47 percent mulattos
bis bi racial half black half
white and the rest of them are
black about nine percent black now
the nigerians um
we have two thousand dead the brazilians
used to be
number two behind us but mexico moved up
to that so
brazil is number three in the world of
dead
331 thousand they have 12.9 almost 13
million infections
nigeria has 2 000 dead and 163 000
infections so it's 13 million more than
163 thousand yeah
is 331 000 dead more than 2
000 did of course so what's the
difference well
nigerians live in west africa and they
eat like asians they live on
maize corn rice sweet potatoes peas
squash and seaweed
you know the seaweed seaweed and algae
from the ocean that's where they get
their trace minerals which their bone
marrow likes
okay then the brazilians they
live on nothing but wheat by the ryan
oates because all of the european
countries that came to brazil brought
their wheat bar around oats with them
and planted it 2 300 years ago and so
that's all they've been eating for 2 300
years they have no defense
that's that's the difference okay 13
million versus 260 thousand
no i take that back 163 thousand um
331 000 dead versus 2000 dead
it's their diet and i got 50 other
comparisons like that
um and so
it's always the asian countries do well
because they live on rice
they don't eat much wheat let's look at
one more the uk
which is england northern ireland uh
scotland
and wales united kingdom uk 67 million
people
let's look at thailand okay let's look
at thailand
which has 67 million people
okay and the uk has 127 000
dead from the covet thailand has 95 dead
the uk has 4.3 million infections
and thailand has 29 000
okay and it's a diet just totally the
diet anytime you compare an asian
country or the european
country or european originating country
the the best results are going to be
with the asians
it's that simple so if everybody
switches over
and eats wild rice and sweet potatoes
and beans and squash and seaweed well i
live in indiana where am i getting a
seaweed well that's why we have few
quiet sea and we have oceans gold
we have ze radical we have all that kind
of stuff with seaweed in it just for
that purpose
and i think that one other piece of the
territory
and that is to maximize the benefit of
the vaccinations you have to get rid of
all the bad foods fried foods processed
meats oils and glutens we brought rhinos
and sugar
and take your 90th nutrients appropriate
for body weight i'd throw in
the z radical and the um uh
ocean's gold and few coins that kind of
stuff for the seaweed
and then um if
if um you don't get the vaccinations and
you eat like an asian and you supplement
properly
the odds are you're going to be like the
asians and you're not going to still
you're going to have a very low chance
of getting the code but if you do get
the cover the odds are you're not going
to die but just taking the vaccinate
vaccination and then eating gluten and
not and not supplementing you're going
to die
you're going to have a very bad case of
the covenant so the vaccination alone
won't save you without getting the
nutrients to your bone marrow
that's the piece that fauci left out
so um uh this
is is all in the book and the histories
in the book
starting with um three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th from
thomas
edison in 1882 and thomas and john
phillips pulled a switch
and goes through the first two chapters
in the book are about wood ashes and
about
all these um people
who did well by putting wood ashes into
their food and into their gardens and
their carrots and beans and squash would
suck up the minerals out of the wood
ashes they eat that food and they did
well
when they switched over to electricity
the doctor's ad just
just just eaten everything you need that
would be like your mechanic travis
saying don't waste your money on oil for
going to the stakes you know that's
bad for the environment and all that
kind of stuff unless you wait for the
oil
no oil but what i want you to do is just
put dirt from texas into your car
it's a six quarts of dirt from texas or
oklahoma
and there's bound to be some oil in that
okay now uh uh uh an insane person would
run away screaming and tell everybody
what a crazy fool that that mechanic is
when your doctor says oh just see well i
get everything you need people say my
doctor says
he went to have it and he says i can get
everything i need by eating while i'm
just wasting my money doing vitamins
minerals well you better start picking
out your coffee now chuck
okay because your doctor is either lying
to you because you've got kids in
college that needs a tuition money
or he's so ignorant i wouldn't send a
dead person to him for an examination
so um with that i think that's a pretty
good summary
if you're going to vaccinate that's fine
but you better be taking your vitamins
and minerals and you better be
supplementing
properly and get rid of the gluten so
you can absorb it
and if you're not going to take a
vaccination you certainly it better
be um getting rid of all the bad foods
and supplementing
and then you will do well so i hope that
helps out
that's awesome yeah that was a great
summation of kind of everything that's
been going on lately so thank you for
that
i'm going to open up for questions but i
do have a few that i want to steal
before
okay okay jump in so kind of circling
back you mentioned
already talking about baby formula the
missing mineral that was
helping with uh sids among other things
now if the mother of a nursing child
is taking that nutrient in higher levels
is that
just as sufficient oh yeah actually
absolutely now when i examined the
sediment death syndrome
when went to federal court you had to
have all these statistics right and so
we found out was
in truth 98 of the kids who were
diagnosed with sid cinnamon syndrome
were in their crib
they weren't in bed with their mother
when they died so i forced them to
change the name from
cinnamon death syndrome to crib death
you've heard about crib death well i'm
the guy that made him change it to that
okay then um the other thing
that i learned was the two percent that
were in bed with her mother when they
died weren't laid on by their mother but
they died of hypertrophy cardiomyopathy
heart disease
which is the keyshawn disease in
heilongjiang china where dr milan i did
the
1700 autopsy so i'm one of the world's
experts
on that disease and so i can look at it
from 100 feet away and
diagnose it right but it's one of those
things where
um doctors had never seen a heart attack
and a you know a three-month-old baby
before so they just
never paid attention to it they just
said well the mother must have laid on
the baby
but but he was in the crib the mother
laid on the baby okay okay okay
that's you know that's how it happened
and people bought it
for years okay well that's why they put
that
um fiberglass sheath on the rail on the
crib of the bed
because the babies used to chew on that
rail on the crib
and they're merely deficient because
there's only three minerals in the baby
farmer
and so that's why they call it cribbing
same with the horse when they get
minerally deficient they show on that
top rail
on the stall in the barn and since their
behavior looks exactly like the behavior
of those babies in the crib they call it
cribbing also for the horses
why they call it a cribbing well that's
because that's what babies did in the
crib
and they're merely deficient that's what
horses do when they're mentally
deficient they chew on the top rail
in the stalls so they call it cribbing
why didn't they call it stalling
that probably wouldn't go over too well
if they called it a stalling
[Laughter]
uh my next question is for someone
that's suffering with high potassium
is there any dietary supplemental or
food things i've heard that eating
like kimchi can be good at lowering
potassium is that
true or what do you know about that well
usually when people have
elevated potassium that means there's
something going on in their liver
and their liver is releasing potassium
because there's some piece missing
somewhere in the body okay and
people can't select and eat potassium
you know just is
you don't find supplements with okay
here's one with a thousand milligrams of
potassium is just take your potassium
pill
no it doesn't work that way usually when
you get a multiple there'll be a little
potassium in there but it's not
like pathological amounts
so when you have an elevated blood
potassium level that means there's
something else going on to make that
happen
the door is closed someplace the
potassium is building up in the blood
because it can't get into where
it belongs so get off of gluten number
one
that's usually where the problem is no
wheat broth rhinos
get them on the 90 essential nutrients
and of course we have secret sauces for
over 600 different diseases
remember my thesis for my 20 000
autopsies is in the smithsonian
institute as a national treasure
it was five thousand pages originally
they
um w b saunders bought the rights to it
okay they made a textbook out of it they
edited it down without re
without reducing any of the scientific
value
they just use one word for 10 words i'm
only 20 something years old so i didn't
know all the words yet right
so i used 10 words and they could use
one word to cover that territory
so they got it down to 1200 pages they
put a hard cover on it made it a
textbook
they first published them in 1970s um
let's see here 19 i think it was 77
maybe 77 or 84 i don't remember
something like that
somewhere in there and anyway they
published it
90 90
yeah 90 000 copies they sold them in
like 30 days for 25 000
each
okay now what i want people to do is go
to siri
when they leave here that's my i'd
already done 20 000 autopsies before i
did that one right that was a big 25
million
project looking for that um
animals in the zoo dying from pollution
that's where that's why all that came
about
anyway um what i want to do
is go ask siri is that booked by dr
wallach diseases of exotic animals
e-x-o-t-i-c diseases of exotic animals
that's all the zoo animals
available for sale and they'll send you
to amazon
and they'll be maybe two three four five
eight ten
fairly cheap compared to twenty five
thousand
but they'll be other offerings you punch
that other offerings and they'll be like
six or eight or ten different divisions
based on the condition of the book
you know the dog has peed on it and
there's a dog here and there's
a lot of writing in the margins and
stuff
you might be able to get that for a low
price and then if it's in pretty good
condition you get it
double that price if that's in pretty
good condition next one
double that and you get pretty close to
000 if it's a library issue that's been
in good condition in the library
environment and so forth um and so it'll
it'll freak you out how much they sell
those books for they're about ready to
publish another batch of because they're
almost all gone
for sale because every library wants one
or two or three or four or five every
medical school wants them
because of the pathology studies in
there
wow that's really really cool i didn't
know that they were coming out with more
so that's really exciting
so i have one more question for you yes
i've found it interesting that we've
talked a little bit about things that
are kind of bad lately
so i'm interested to know what your
thoughts are on cold therapy such as
cold showers
you know ice baths that kind of thing do
you know of any health benefits
related to those things
well they can sort of stimulate
circulation a little bit
uh it's just kind of like a lazy man's
exercise thing cold shower kind of stuff
if you're just thinking about girls all
the time take a cold shower that quiets
you down
kind of thing right that's infamous but
that's it um
there's there's otherwise there's no
therapeutic value in that
um what you want to do um is find out if
you're absorbing things that's very
important
now you get the book um rare urgent
cures in chapter nine and ten tells you
how to collect your hair
how to package it where to ship it to
don't forget to put the check in there
because it won't run the test without
the check but it'll tell you if you're
absorbing all of the
um essential nutrients it'll tell you
also if you have toxic minerals
lead and and mercury and stuff like that
it'll tell if you have those kind of
minerals in you also
and so you look at your hair analysis
when you get it back in about two weeks
if all the bars represent each of the
different nutritional minerals or below
the bottom line that means you're not
absorbing
they're kind of all over the place and
you're not supplementing but they're all
over the place because you're just
eating well all these i need to really
supplement these well if you really need
supplement for instance
um sometimes people call me say man my
calcium and my magnesium is off the roof
i mean it's just above the top line on
the chart
the doctor says i can't even read the
label on a calcium body let alone take
anything i got
too much calcium so no you need to fire
your doctor because your doctor is an
idiot
what that means is you're so deficient
in calcium your parathyroid glands are
pulling all the calcium out of your
bones
and that's why your calcium is so high
in your blood which is why it's high in
your hair analysis
you can't eat enough calcium to make
your blood calcium go up that high
okay well that's where all my autopsies
came in because i'm covering
diet and all the other diseases plus
hair analysis and stuff
for the 25 million dollars i was able to
do hair analysis on all those 20
000 autopsies and so
this is something that
doctors don't know much about also it'll
tell you if you have toxic metals in you
and of course the book raresman cures
tells you
what supplements to take to get rid of
the toxic minerals
this is very easy you don't need to go
in for iv
chelation for 300 bucks an hour you know
and do that for six months
to get rid of all that it's very simple
you take supplements and and exercise a
little bit sweat a little bit
and they all all the bad stuff goes away
and um so anyway this is
the again the book hell's kitchen the cd
hell's kitchen
um gives you the history and all these
pandemics tells you how to deal with
them
the red warning light cd that pharmacist
keith and i put together
red warning lights goes into i don't
know eight or nine different um
pre-existing conditions that say you're
going to have a bad time with covet if
you get it like obesity is a big one
85 of the people who die of covert are
obese
which is caused by a mineral deficiency
okay because their bone marrow is dead
because their bone marrow required that
mineral
because they're deficient in it not only
did you get obese but your bone marrow
is dead
that's why people go into doctors once a
month for an iron shot and a b12 shot
because they tried taking iron pills and
b12 pills didn't work because their
intestines are dead they couldn't absorb
the pills
they had to go in for a shot people get
tired they'd say well i could give you
every two months i could give you a
transfusion and give you red blood cells
and
and platelets and white blood cells and
stuff like that from somebody else so
let's try that
i was sick for 10 days after he gave me
that transfusion what else you got
well let's do a bone marrow transplant
it's only a hundred thousand dollars but
don't worry about it your insurance will
pay for it
surgery was success the operation was
success and the patient died
okay all these are caused by eating
gluten and not supplementing
so i hope that kind of gets people
thinking in the right direction here
but it's all in that book and cd it's
all in the book black gene lies in the
cd black sea lions it's all in the book
and the cd immortality it goes into all
the things that the long-lived people do
these people their country their average
lifespan is
165. with us it's 75.
emergency room surgeons their average
lifespan according to cdc just a couple
of months ago
was 57. they don't do very well why
would you listen to them about health
now you get run over by a truck you need
to go to the emergency room
but you know obviously they don't know
what to do to stay alive longer than 57.
that's their um on record according to
the cdc
and then my last one i'll turn it back
to you is johns hopkins very famous
medical school
and university in baltimore maryland
very famous
one of the u.s
congressmen from baltimore maryland
elijah cummings
this got to be about two years ago now
he developed
atrial fibrillation and they convinced
him it was a heart disease and they said
we got to do an abolition we got to
anesthetize you cut your chest open put
a hot soldering iron on your chest
on your heart and to stop it from doing
crazy things
he agreed to it and they killed him with
the surgery elijah cummings
it's not a hard thing it's osteoporosis
of the skull squeezing the 10th cranial
nerve
which controls the right rhythm of your
heart
obviously opposed to the skull very
common that's why we have the book
called it's all in your head
there's 25 different diseases you get
from osteoporosis skull but a doctor
never tells you
did you have austria have you ever heard
that before i mentioned it
travis not before we uh you brought it
to our attention a couple months ago
yeah but they always talk about
osteoporosis in your leg bones and arm
bones your vertebrae and that kind of
stuff and they never talk about the
skull
because that's how they send their kids
to college the tuition money right
and they that's because their their
tennis
partner and their golf buddy
okay a ted's partner and golf buddy has
osteoporosis
or treat people with osteoporosis skull
you know they are
neurologists they are um ear nose and
throat doctors
they do hearing aid things they're
dentists
um they deal with vision problems and
blindness i mean i've had so many wagers
with doctors i've won so much money
and free steak dinners and stuff like
that from doctors
because i take their blind people and in
90 days to get them reading
2020 without glasses and they couldn't
equivocate because they were the ones
that picked the patients who were
legally blind six eight ten years so
they couldn't
argue with the diagnosis because the
ones that diagnosed him as being blind
six eight ten twelve years
and just 90 days i got him all um one
doctor gave me 27
and in 90 days i could all read 20 20.
he didn't like me very much because he
had to pay for the supplements for all
the as part of the wager for
all the patients
so all that kind of stuff is in the book
it's all in your head
every family needs to have that book and
they need to at least read you know one
chapter a week
and share with everybody in the family
because
every disease your doctor wants to milk
your insurance i mean
charge your insurance okay
it's in your head is caused by
osteoporosis of the skull
tinnitus ringing in the ears vertigo
yeah yeah so i'm going to open it up i
think
i saw come in on instagram devin if you
want to unmute and jump in i know i saw
a couple coming on there
if you want to okay i have a question um
so where can we get this hair analysis
done i want to do that okay sounds
pretty cool okay what you do
is you go to www.drjwalik.com
www.dr.js get a hold of the book you
know
um uh travis may have one he can sell
you
it's called rare earth forbidden cures
it tells you how to collect the hair how
to package it where to ship it
how much to send in a check with it and
um
phone numbers and all the kind of
stuff's in there saying call the lab and
confirm everything
but we've been doing this for
20 years and what's the name of the test
what do they call that panel
it's called a hair analysis
just a hair analysis and test for all
kinds of minerals basically
yeah nutritional metals and nutritional
minerals and toxic minerals
okay for them to do a blood test on
you yeah see your body works real hard
to keep your blood
in optimal levels in all things you
could be seriously deficient
and 50 are your 90 essential nutrients
but your blood test will show everything
normal because your your body's working
overtime to keep your blood levels
normal
you can be deficient and you have all
these diseases which are caused by the
deficiency but yet your blood test is
normal
and so that's why we do the hair
analysis because that's the only way you
can get the truth
and you know there's people who are all
like bowling balls they don't have a
hair on their head they can use pubic
hair
actually hair on your arm chest hair
but you just you do have to tell them
where the hair is from because results
be a little bit different based on the
location of the hair
and you don't need much you only need
like a heaping tablespoon of hair
awesome thank you all right devin should
be able to jump in now sorry about that
doc
making you wait there hey doc so a
couple of questions coming in online
one is what are your thoughts on zeolite
that's a mineral i think what are your
thoughts on zeolite your thoughts on
pink
salt the benefits of pink salt and also
is alkaline alkaline
alkalinity of myth
okay let's start out with salt okay
um we have a saver division and
youngevity you know we have six
um let's see i think we have 6 000
products now
and all our spices and salad dressings
and
stuff like that and and culinary stuff
is in our saber division it's called
savor like you savor the taste of this
for the flavor and um one of our great
products
in there is pink himalayan salt we have
a pink himalayan salt it comes in a
little canister
kind of like a where you get chew in the
back that kind of size canister
and then we have the pink himalayan salt
with ground black pepper in it
i take the pink himalayan salt on my
poached eggs for breakfast
and my rice i take three heaping scoops
full of
wild rice for breakfast and i put my
pink himalayan salt on and then for
dinner time i'll have sweet potatoes and
our rice
and i'll use the pink himalayan salt
with the black pepper ground up in it
and there okay and so that's the salt
thing you know
you require salt many many many many
many many many many diseases are caused
by a salt deficiency
because you cannot digest food you
cannot break down
proteins you cannot absorb iron you
cannot absorb b12 without salt
uh you'll get bloating belching burping
and all kinds of bad stomach issues
without salt
because the chloride part of salt you
know sodium chloride the chloride part
of salt
helps you make hydrochloric acid which
is required to break down
amino acids proteins into amino acids
and also it keeps your stomach
environment acid where everything all
your digestion works
okay if chief cells you have chief cells
in the walls of your stomach they
actually
convert salt into stomach acid okay
that's why the chief cells are in there
to convert salt into stomach acid
and that keeps it acid so the bacteria
cannot grow in there
you're not eating salt because your
doctor incorrectly
told you oh don't take salt to give you
high blood pressure that doctor should
go to jail as being a mass murderer
okay and they should um
what happens is bacteria begin to grow
in your stomach
as soon as the ph begins to get neutral
or alkaline
okay above seven seven point one seven
by two you're you're alkaline
you need to be a two your stomach
environment needs to be at two
ph okay acid acid acid acid
and so um but then you have to remember
the doctors make their money by treating
the symptoms the only
pharmaceutical that cures anything is is
antibiotics that kill
bacteria all other pharmaceuticals just
treat symptoms
doctors are in the business of managing
the disease they want to treat your
rheumatoid arthritis for 40 years
they don't want to get rid of it in 40
days i can get rid of your rheumatoid
arthritis in 40 days
they want to treat it for 40 years okay
and then um so the alkaline thing um you
do not you do not want to be alkaline
and some crazy hippies idea of something
good uh they don't know what they're
talking about you do not want to be
alkaline you want your stomach
environment to be
um acid your tissues will be
kind of neutral okay and it varies from
different organs and cells and things
but it'll be around neutral give or take
a little bit
and zeolite and that's another company
um and so basically i would just tell
you
that i use that when i mix up
concrete but i don't eat it i use our
um our minerals or bloom and minerals
which are plant minerals
zeolite as the name implies is made from
roundup rocks
anybody at home sorry i was i wasn't
sure if uh
you had anything else i didn't want to
jump in and cut you off i think that's
super helpful
um would you mind just talking a little
bit more on the alkaline do you think
that drinking alkaline water is
important or should we just be focusing
on
purified or i know we have icelandic
water but i'm not sure what the ph is on
that
okay icelandic water is acid and i drink
two quarts a day that's why i put my
btt 2.0 powder in okay my osteo beyond
ico fx i put all that powder stuff like
that in there
and i put my cardio effects stick powder
in there i put those three things in
there i've been doing that for like 30
years
okay but i've been putting in just
somebody else's water which is neutral
but ours is acid and of course iceland
is having all these volcanic eruptions
so
our water is going to have more minerals
in it now okay
because of volcanic eruptions
and so and i also like our
um uh
icelandic water as a
which i say is a gift to people when
they come over
and give them a bottle of that and he's
boy this is something else
okay and so they've never really
consumed really
really good mineral water now you have
to appreciate
that you've heard the blue zones where
people live a long time they have a high
rate of 100 year olds on these blue
zones there's five of them
they're all polynesian islands
are polynesian
[Music]
appendages off of islands where they've
had volcanic eruptions
they have all these minerals from the
volcano okay and they're eating algae
and all this kind of stuff
and these are the peoples who have the
highest rate of living a long time
now um in the 20th century the longest
person was a
um woman by the name of um jean calment
from france
okay she died at 122. well documented
and then um
just i don't know a couple of months ago
there's a catholic
nun who just recovered from covid
at 116 years of age and she came from
the same town that gene calment came
from
and she turned 117 and she's doing very
well now even though she had the covid
at 116 and she survived it because she's
drinking all that mineral water
there in this one town in france
and then there was a guy by the name of
dr lee chen yun
okay do you ever hear of the book or the
movie
lost horizon yeah
okay no
plus horizon okay yeah
james hilton very good yeah well he
wrote he spent
a year tracking this dr lee chen yun
okay and it was real and so he
wrote it up as a newspaper article for
the new york times and the london times
there was such a good response he came
up with the book and the movie 1933 and
1937 respectively
but this is where the longest of people
on earth live because it's all volcanic
stuff
and they don't have electricity and so
they're still using wood for fuel and
they're putting the wood ashes into
their gardens
and it's not unusual i i have in my
presentation
on my computer people it's it's in the
new york times it's
it's in the chicago uh newspapers it's
in this
um la newspapers and so forth the miami
herald and so on
what happens is they show these guys
they're in a garden and sharks and a
t-shirt kind of rolled up
okay up to their belly so their belly
can get some sun i
um so and so here abdul shalami
is uh he's his his birthday he's 165
years old today
well documented he's out working in the
garden at 165.
well that's because they're eating all
these wood ashes with the volcanic
minerals in the wood ash because the
trees suck up those minerals
okay in the guilt our glacier in hunza
is where this place is called hunza
valley
and one valley in hunza is called
shangri-la
and that was a place in the book uh
lost horizon where people lived to be
over a hundred and everybody thought
that was a mythical place no
it's a real place but it was so
outrageously crazy
that all the doctors said that's got to
be a lie it can't be true but
it's true
so there you go well i i love hearing
that man just
the fact that we have the potential to
live so long and live so healthy
i'm gonna open it up we got a few more
minutes about two more minutes sure
i believe he's on here dylan if brooke
has anything else uh i've got one more
question yeah
um this is my question uh
they say they put fluoride in the water
for dental reasons
any issues with that does it really
cause people to become more docile
and compliant with government wishes etc
okay you have to appreciate that
fluorine is is an essential nutrient
is required for many things including
it's a cofactor to help
put minerals into your bone matrix okay
and again you have to appreciate
um that people like hippies
when they you know wanted for one reason
or another he said oh
you can't put fluorine in the water but
they followed vitamin d3 they put in the
milk
because there were so many kids with
rickets when they had the industrial
revolution
and all the smoke blocking out the sun
rays and kids weren't getting enough
sunlight
and they weren't eating liver and stuff
like that so they weren't getting enough
vitamin d and everybody was getting
rickets
okay and so they put um vitamin d3 in
the milk
they start to be putting nutrients into
drinks
okay that's why they begin to put
nutrients into drinks that's why we have
a sports drink called rebound that has
100 nutrients and 75
minerals and rebound okay i take people
um for instance
and again it's all kind of this
government thing
and the hippies that's how they get
other hippies to do what they want by
telling them all the government is going
to kill you by putting fluorine in your
drinking water and blah blah blah
this is science called crapola
okay get a hair analysis see how much
fluorine you have in your hair
so i'm more worried about fluorine as a
free radical
in general uh what's your take on that
um well uh let's see here
what should i say but have you ever
heard
of um olive oil of course yeah
what do you think about olive oil lots
of free radical damage
yes olive oil gives you a million times
more free radical damage than fluorine
the only time chlorine will kill you is
you make a bullet out of the dry powder
and shoot yourself with it
why is olive oil so rampant for
free radical activity because it has so
many
double bonds in there it oxidizes and
turns into trans fats heterozygote means
acrylamides
and causes cancer this also causes
plaque in your arteries cholesterol does
not cause
plaque in your arteries cholesterol is
an essential nutrient makes up 75
of your brain weight and 95 of
testosterone and 95 percent of estrogen
cholesterol is one of your best friends
and so when you get statin drugs
there was no such thing as alzheimer's
disease prior to 1960. now
there are dementias and little people
getting senile dementia
there's over a dozen different dementias
and senile dementias right and
loss of memory but alzheimer's as a
specific entity did not exist until 1960
when they came out with statin drugs to
lower your cholesterol because they
believed falsely that
cholesterol was the cause of plaque in
your arteries
now very few people have done more
autopsies than me
okay and again that's what my thesis is
in the smithsonian institute's national
treasure
and again i urge you to
uh look them up ask siri are there any
of my
dr wallach's book diseases of exotic
animals available for sale
and they'll give you what the lowest
prices are but then there'll be
other options or other offerings and hit
that and then it'll list
books that are in better condition
better condition new and so on and it'll
give
it'll blow your mind how much they
charge for those books
it's been a textbook since i think
nineteen
19 84.
i'm gonna have to get one of those
someday soon here so
start saving your pennies i have my
change jar
with my five gallon jug so let's bring
it home i wanted to ask about
cholesterol just in general
i know you just kind of spoke on it but
as being part of your your dream and we
know how important cholesterol is
but a lot of people don't so it's kind
of talking about the benefits and the
uses of cholesterol across the whole
body
and why we need it so badly
well again is the base that your
glands make hormones from okay people
with ed they're going to give you
injections of
of um testosterone or give you
testosterone pills and everything
but really all you have to do is um uh
you know uh he eats eat
eggs i ate three eggs twice i'm 82 years
old i don't have problems
okay i ate three eggs twice a day soft
soft boiled
and then again they didn't have
alzheimer's disease
until 1960. now doctors now
every dementia you can name now they've
changed the name to alzheimer's disease
why do they do that well when you look
at the payout
for all these other dementias and senile
dementia and so forth
it's a pittance compared to what they
pay out to treat alzheimer's disease
so any dementia you have your doctor's
gonna name it alzheimer's disease now
this is worth a two minute story here if
i may take for two minutes
oh yeah i've got plenty of time so
this goes back 20 something years ago a
gal calls me up and says my brother ray
mcgregor
uh was diagnosed 11 years earlier with
um alzheimer's disease the doctors put
him on pharmaceuticals for alzheimer's
disease and at the three-year mark he
goes into a coma
he's been in a coma in a nursing home
for eight years now being fed
insured through a g-tube okay you know
that
liquid oil artificial food through a
g-tube three times a day he's got zero
brain waves now
duh and uh they want to pull the plug on
him
to get somebody in there who can
probably live they say he's not going to
live so they need to pull the plug
we'll get 90 days i said i want you to
get our shake
our um either our chocolate or
strawberry shake
make it with heavy cream instead of
water i wanted to have three of those a
day through his g-tube you're going to
have to do it because they're not going
to do at the nursing home
then i want you to also give him
um our rebound okay i want him to have
a couple ounces of that in that shake i
also want him to have
three poached eggs three times a day
blend it up in the shake with a blender
then i want him to have
the de-stress capsules there's two
different types of dimensions that can
result from deficiencies and stuff
that's
in there so i'm going to take uh three
of those capsules three times a day
the ultimate niacin plus one of those
three times a day
and then i also want him to have the
ultimate daily classic calculus in case
it's a vascular dimension
plugged arteries in the brain you can
take three of those in each meal
okay and then i want him to take some
anti-inflammatory things
okay like our fucoid z which is our
um seaweed stuff okay if you quite see
if you want to use the liquids you don't
have to blend them up
you can just use our liquid seed
radicals the same thing as seaweed
give them an ounce of the z radical in
each of the three meals and call me
every two weeks and let me know what the
doctor says and so on well she calls me
in three days and she's screaming his
name out crying and wailing oh god
he's dying they're gonna blame me ray
mcgregor she gives in ray mcgregor is
her brother's name
he said well tell me about your brother
ray how's he doing well he woke up this
morning he didn't realize he was in a
coma for eight years
after just three days on my program he
wakes up
shaves goes back to work as an officer
in the bank now the people at the bank
there
at that day weren't there eight years
earlier and they think he's just a
clever crook trying to claim he's a bank
officer
and rob the bank so they call the cops
she says the bank is swarming with cops
because they called nobody recognized
him as a as a bank officer which he was
when he went into his coma
uh eight years earlier and
and so that's my experience with
alzheimer's disease i i get rid of
alzheimer's disease
by the thousands every year because it's
either alzheimer's disease or one of the
other dementias but they all go away
because they're all nutritional
deficiencies
just incredible that we can turn things
around so quickly for people
and really help impact so many lives so
i have you for two more minutes i'm
gonna ask you one more question
sure you always mention when we're
talking about different protocols you
say the 12 bad foods but you also always
add sugar
do you think that sugar should be added
to the list and made it 13 bad foods
well um a teaspoon of honey today is
fine
but pure white sugar okay
you require a lot of nutrition to deal
with it
um when you're when you're metabolically
you have to
metabolize the sugar put it into a shape
you can use it for fuel and all that
kind of stuff or turn it into fat
requires a lot of nutrition to do that
whereas honey
you don't need so much nutrition to do
it we're designed to deal with honey
if you've read the bible or had somebody
read it to you remember
where was the perfect land where did
people live the longest and the
healthiest
the land flowing with milk and honey
okay that goes back to bible days 2000
years ago so they were observing it
without knowing all the
biochemical details they're just
observing hey where there is milk and
honey
people didn't have these problems okay
so
that's what i use if i'm going to put
sugar in something i just use um
honey i don't never use sugar i
always use a pink himalayan salt i
rebound
or sports drink healthy being a heart
pack
and of course we're the guys that got
evander holyfield he's gonna he's gonna
have a fight again here coming up pretty
soon
um he um had a heart attack fighting
michael moore and he lost the fight
because he had a heart attack
and um we invented our healthy brain
heart pack for him he was on it for a
year and a half he came back and he beat
iron mike tyson got his championship
back who comes back from a near fatal
heart attack and wins a heavyweight
championship
fight okay healthy brain and heart pack
only people with the help of you dr
wallach thank you so much for taking
time tonight to talk with us
if you're on the call and you would like
to stick around we can do questions we
can chat after this
but thank you dr wallach uh we'll give
you a call soon and hopefully set up our
next one but
okay thank you travis lieutenant colonel
wallach over and out thank you sir